quel est l'état de santé de bernard
tapie ce matin l'état de santé et
honnêtement très préoccupant puisqu'il a
des apparitions de nouvelles tumeurs
depuis quelques jours les premières ont
commencé quelques semaines donc
aujourd'hui au moment où on se parle il
y en a une au cerveau qui doit être
soignée par radiothérapie
il y en a deux dans les reins qui
doivent être soignés par cryogénie il en
a dans l'abdomen
il en a un peu partout après de petite
taille je vous cache pas que les changes
les chances statistiques quand on à ce
stade là sont épouvantables il est
extrêmement fatiguée et c'est en ça que
c'est absolument plus ce qui est
incompréhensible scandaleux que la cour
n'ait pas souhaité ce record eh ben je
voudrais remercier philippe hersen être
avec nous mais nos metteurs en scène
notamment de bernard tapie
je sais vous êtes un proche de bernard
merci fini d'être avec nous je suis très
heureux de le voir philippe ou plus que
j'adore est ce que vous pensez vous qu
on aurait dû reporter le procès de
bernard tapie
philippe est ce que vous avez quelques
nouvelles vous de votre corps oui j'ai
des nouvelles de bernard pages les huits
hier matin bon c'est vrai qu'il y avait
pas grand grand grand moral bernard hier
matin c'est vrai j'ai eu brièvement mais
on n'a pas besoin de dire grand-chose
insurgés tellement bien
on a vraiment comment annoncer mon père
aurait eu grand chose avec bernard c'est
vrai que je trouve ça inadmissible c'est
scandaleux ce qui se passe c'est
vraiment vous en a permis ou pas oui
mais brièvement sur tout ce qui est
important pour lui c'est si sa santé
c'est sûr primordial même par rapport à
ce combat c'est combat pour sa santé ses
combats pour la vie c'est plus même que
le combat judiciaire en plus qu'il avait
été relaxé en première instance et ça
qui assure immuable pas possible bien
sûr
alors on a vu là la réaction de rente a
pu en voir d'autres extraits dans un
instant vous dit tout cela autour de la
table gilbert dette sur le plan humain
c'est absolument choquant et sur le plan
du droit ya aucun motif c'est
incompréhensible c'est un procès en
appel face à une cour d'appel réputé
hostile à bernard tapie on l'empêchent
de dévoiler de donner ses arguments de
se défendre
donc soit on attend qu'ils puissent y
être soit on reporte et on dit on ne
reporte pas parce qu'on sait pas à
quelle date le mec le procès franchement
c'est scandaleux alors
à les regarder pour justifier le
maintien de ce procès la justice se
reposait sur deux arguments qui ne
serait pas recevable selon le fils de
bernard tapie laurent nous arguments le
premier c'est celui du temps de dire ah
ben on a vu mais le prochain calendrier
disponible c'est avril 2022 c'est pas un
argument qui est recevable je suis
désolé si la justice est lente c'est le
problème de la justice c'est le boulot
du ministre de la réforme et c'est pas
aux gens qui sont malades de subir les
conséquences des lenteurs de la justice
le deuxième argument c'est de dire de
toute manière ça suit là elle est
exceptionnelle sa présence n'est pas
indispensable puisque j'ai pu prendre
connaissance de tous ses arguments de
défense développé lors de la première
instance dont je les ai donc on pourra
continuer sans mais c'est
invraisemblable c'est comme extrêmement
à la fois étonnant et alarmant parce que
ça veut dire qu'il est probable qu'elle
ait déjà pris sa décision
philippe hersen comprenait la décision
de la justice
pas du tout pas du tout on peut dire
c'est là la justice de cette justice à
plusieurs étages je pense réellement fin
moi personnellement je pense que laurent
à paris où les enfants de bernard je
pense que le juge a dû déjà prendre sa
décision
c'est pas possible autrement s'est pas
présenté six avaient parité bernard
tapie aux horreurs porter complètement
complètement sûr bien sûr
ouais c'est vrai quoi c'est l'homme à
abattre encore bernard tapie l'homme est
là bas at oui bien sûr mais là je pense
qu'il l'a vu déjà l'appel c'était
l'appel se passe pas très bien alors
qu'en première instance s'est beaucoup
mieux passé quand il est rentré dans le
tribunal il a vu que de la juge étaient
plus neutre que ce que cet appel 6-2 me
savais qu'en plus on suspend pas eu des
procès ont déclenché des raisons la
dernière fois j'ai vu donc terroristes
le terroriste du talent ici là une
suspension d' une suspension d'audience
parce qu'ils avaient des vomissements et
de la fièvre monsieur azibert non le
procès sarkozy bismuth pareil suspension
d'audience parce qu'il avait des
problèmes de santé
donc là franchement c'est
incompréhensible c'est incroyable pour
ses séries mais c'est pas ces contres
bien c'est contre ben oui moi je suis
toujours pour me dire que tout le monde
est justiciable il n'y a pas de passe
droit pour personne sauf que là on est
en train de parler de l'humain on sait
que c'est quelqu'un qui s'est fait
agresser ya pas longtemps que c'est
quelqu'un qui est très malade en ce
moment on adresse une pensée assez
proche il va il va pas bien du tout en
ce moment et moi j'aimerais bien
comprendre cette justice à deux vitesses
où on explique bernard tapie qui est
très malade qui a un cancer qui a une
tumeur qui est premier on parle de
l'humain
on s'en fout on parle d'un procès ont
dit lui même en a rien à [ __ ] faut
qu'il aille au procès ont connu le
procès et de l'autre côté jeu monsieur
patrick balkany demi en prison il a des
courbatures il a un rhume on le fait
sortir pour qu'ils aillent danser sur la
place de la mairie prévoit pas à macina
si tu fais sortir de prison
et là tu veux tu peux en juger si ces
savoirs à la baisse des doutes mais
c'est ça n'a rien à voir là vous la
route est à côté de la plage avait de
quoi perturber la quiétude c'est que
c'est toujours l'arbitrage de 2008
c'est-à-dire salah de 13 ans et
aujourd'hui on veut pas attendre trois
mois qu à savoir ce qui l'attend il
attend depuis 13 ans et le combat de sa
vie
je trouve ça millions franchement c'est
humiliant et c'est inexplicable
et puis oui normalement oui mais ça
c'est l'élève sait les problèmes de la
justice oui normalement les prochaines
dates c'est prévu mais au printemps 22
majeur si on va plus loin et ce sont des
très cynique on peut se demander même
s'ils n'ont pas décidé ça parce qu'ils
se disent il est tellement malade que
finalement ça pourra pas les mieux donc
on le fait maintenant c'est ça qu'ils
boivent qui ment rivalité se demande
même s'il s'est passé dans ce sens là
pourquoi il s'adressait selon sous
pression selon laurent tapie cette
décision prise par la juge est bien pire
que ce qu'a vécu bernard tapie il ya
quelques semaines lors du violent
cambriolage dont il a été victime
pour lui cette décision est encore pire
aussi horrible soit elle cette agression
dans l'échelle de ce qu'on vit elle est
anecdotique quand vous faites agresser
par des bandits professionnels bon bah y
ait des gens comme ça qui existe là ce
qu'on a eue hier pour moi c'est pire que
cette agression avait pas ce que c'est
des juges a cédé gens qui sont censés
rendre le droit pour le peuple français
quand c'est eux qui vous agressent de
cette manière je trouve sa pire que
quand c'est des cambrioleurs voilà c'est
vrai que c'est fort ce que dit lors au
tapis un wiki les et c'était le combat
de sa vie
oui on l'en priver et très franchement
on a vraiment l'impression que c'est
joué d'avancé et que celle qu'on appelle
lé politisée au sens où elle veut se
payer bernard tapie et l'a dit laurent
tapie mais oui hélas elle est ça a l'air
d'être ça et la juge en fait elle dit
mais j'ai pas besoin de l'entendre je
sais déjà tout sous-entendu j'ai déjà
tranché et ça c'est horrible c'est
vraiment ça ne devrait pas exister
et oui philippe qu'est ce qui dit
bernard surtout ça je pense que berne à
sa priorité c'est vraiment c'est sa
santé
c'est tellement
un frein à sa santé ça ça cesse et pawel
mais ses combats il a tellement eu de
combat dans sa vie bernard que pour lui
c'était moi il m'a toujours dit le reste
le plus important que je cuisine le plus
important jusqu'à ce que j'ai ce procès
qui dure depuis pratiquement trente ans
c'était tellement important pour lui
céder le seul combat pour lui c'est le
combat de sa vie ça va certains croient
quoi le faire maintenant si je suis si
quand même pourquoi le faire maintenant
son procès ça fait trente ans qu'elle
savait trop je suis d'accord mais non un
homme qui est en train mais je pense que
bernard veut justement oui faire c'est
le combat de sa vie oui oui il veut au
clan bien sûr il faut maintenant voir si
ça en tout cas
ou est-ce que vous avez encore confiance
en la justice quand vous entendez
s'assure non un art tapis ou alors ils
maintenant sur le dossier franchement il
a été relaxé une première fois
tout le monde y jugement de 200 pages
c'est un des dossiers moi je les
consulte et en partie j'ai essayé de
lire les plus construit les arguments me
et stéphane que j'embrasse fort stéphane
tapis mon ami elle a refusé une
expertise médicale pour prendre sa
décision mais ça c'est ça anormal pas
normal ça n'est pas normal du tout bas
oui on en ville mais c'est incroyable
c'est à dire qu'on lui refuse tout et
très franchement déjà l'appel bon
ensuite le fait qu'on lui refuse les
expertises il n'est pas là du coup ces
invocations vont pas d'argumentaire
c'est un procès à charge mais c'est ça
qui me choque
je le dis avec émotion c'est un procès à
charge contre bernard tapie habile et on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui en france
instruire un procès à charge c'est à
charge et à décharge et là y'a pas s'il
n'y a pas attaqué dans ces cas là non
non non ne même pas là le procès en
train de se continue il va se continuer
il ya encore pour une huitaine de jours
oui essence et un fossé en sens inverse
sur ses avocats bien sûr et sans bernard
bien sûr laissant ses avocats avaient
sûr comme il y avait comme il est
hospitalisé bernard dont on a vu un
renard dans une interview qui disait
qu'il avait envie de revenir sur scène
louis 7 eia ouais ça fait trois ans were
devait revenir sur les 20 ans de les 20
ans de tu connais tu te rappelles tu
nous vois le dessus d'être coupée en
deux et monter une comédie musicale
oui bah ouais mais encore il ya un petit
mois il m'a dit afin peut-être penser
parce que c'est un battant berne a
peut-être pensé
projet allait pour la rentrée pourquoi
pas ouais il est ce serait non pour
l'abattre faut vraiment s'y met c'est
que vous êtes sur un projet alors vous
ayez sur un projet de pièce flip avec
ses 8 travail avec ses 8 c'est vrai ou
pas c est à beyrouth
fin juillet le maurice ma femme
s'appelle maurice j'ai proposé
naturellement cyril d'avoir le premier
rôle le rôle dans tout cas de laspalès
c'est vrai eh bien écoutez et lagoin
groupe l'année où j'ai dit à philippe
durr non j'ai pas dit non j'ai pas dit
oui je vais regarder ça avec ses 8 mai
c'est vrai que la spa laissé tellement
bond dont j'ai encore revu la dans la
foire elle et je voulais je compte est
appelé pour tenir là
si l'intéressé ou pas mais c'est vrai
que là ce palais c'est tellement
incroyable dedans que c'est compliqué de
reprendre le rôle et il est dur mais on
en parle on entend alors mis d'appeler
ça on va en parler tous les deux m'ont
philippe mais c'est vrai que ça serait
énorme de trait au théâtre et sera bien
sûr celles reçues sur la spa et bains